Tereza may already ten rounds into her
latest brexit battle before she even
began this hastily convened early
evening press conference I'm gonna do my
job of getting the best deal for Britain
I'm going to do my job of getting a deal
that is in the national interest when
the vote comes before the House of
Commons MPs will be doing their job they
will need to look at that a deal they
will need to consider the vote of the
British people to leave the European
Union and our duty to deliver on that
vote and of course they will be held to
account by their constituents for the
decisions that they take after a day in
which her partying government seemed to
be unraveling the Prime Minister
appealed directly to voters and with a
message to those MPs tonight trying to
depose her she stay in put I believe
that this is a deal which does deliver
that which is in the national interest
and am I going to see this through yes
an impressive performance given how her
day started none other than mrs. Mays
brexit secretary resigning before she'd
even got out of the door a cabinet deal
done on the terms of Praxis last night
in tatters by the morning the Prime
Minister's still soldiering on raised
for impact in the Commons I being
committed day and night to delivering on
the result of the referendum
and ensuring the u.k leaves the EU
absolutely and on time I know it's been
a frustrating process it has forced us
to confront some very difficult issues
but a gooda brexit a brexit which is in
the national interest is possible we
have persevered and have made a decisive
breakthrough but in reality she'd hit a
wall on all sides no support from labour
the government simply cannot put to
Parliament this half-baked deal that
both a brexit secretary and his
predecessor have rejected her DEP allies
confirming that they're supplying
confidence being now dead she clearly
doesn't listen and can I say today that
this house now has a clear choice and
every member in it we stand up for the
United Kingdom the whole of the United
Kingdom the integrity of the United
Kingdom or we vote for a vassal state
with the breakup of the United her own
team full of Menace - as they move their
leader leaving no doubt she was now
facing a full-blown leadership crisis
these 585 pages are a testament to
broken promises failed negotiations and
abject capitulation to the EU this
backstop is completely intolerable and I
feel confident that even in the unlikely
event that legislation for it reaches
this house it will be ferociously
opposed over 80 Tory backbenchers when
it's 84 now and it's going up by the out
will vote against it so I plead with you
I plead with you to accept the political
reality of the situation you now face
this leading brexit it all but
confirming who's going to try and topple
her in a no confidence vote as well my
right honourable friend says and what my
right Uncle Fred does no longer match
should I not right - my right honourable
friend the member for ultrium and sail
west
forty eight letters needed to call a
vote MPs convinced it's now only a
question of when not if after all that
drama a theatrical press conference
outside Parliament successes already
being muted to start with you've got
Boris Johnson and David Davis and you've
got Dominic Robin estimate ver you've
got penny Morton you have streams of
talent within the Conservative Party who
would be very capable of support of
leading a proper breaks in the former
brexit secretary who set off this
morning's chain of resignations
insistent he still wanted missus made to
continue but admitting he did not know
if she could do you think she will be
Prime Minister than on brexit day next
year I certainly hope so
and I'll be supporting her to make a
successor break say and make a success
of her Premiership but hope is different
from confidence right well I don't know
I can't predict this if it you know
tumultuous on certain times frantic
brief and in all directions in
Westminster today but some staying out
of the fray brexit is Michael Gove penny
mordant and Andrea led some all still on
resignation watch the Prime Minister end
in the day insisting that she is still
very much in the game one of my cricket
heroes was always Geoffrey Boycott
and what did you know about Geoffrey
Boycott Geoffrey Boycott stuck to it and
he got the runs in the end thank you
still batten on tonight but the pitch
ever more hostile Beth Rigby Sky News